what would happen if you flew into a
wormhole would you ever hear back where
would you end up back in time another
galaxy this is what if and here's what
would happen if a wormhole formed in our
solar system you've probably heard of
wormholes through Thor interstellar Star
Trek or if you're really old-school
Albert Einstein in 1935 Albert Einstein
and physicist Nathan Rosen came up with
the idea of bridges in space-time WTF
oMG sounds like you're catching on
because an einstein-rosen bridge or a
wormhole is also a shortcut through
space-time a wormhole is less like a
bridge and more like a tunnel it's a
tunnel that links two different points
in space-time and if you were to pass
through it you could end up in a
different galaxy a different universe or
14th century Europe but only if you
found a way to keep the wormhole from
collapsing on you the trouble is no
one's ever seen a more moat before and
we probably won't find one any time soon
the other problem is if we're moles do
exist in our solar system
they're probably microscopic any
wormhole that could accommodate human
travel would require a crazy amount of
mass think about it the smallest black
hole is thought to be the size of an
atom but with the mass of a mountain so
while we can't really calculate the mass
of a wormhole that could fit a few of us
and a spaceship just know that it would
be astronomical and its gravitational
pull would probably redirect the tilt
and rotation of all the planets in our
solar system but things would go back to
normal soon enough wormholes are
incredibly unstable and are prone to
collapse quickly this is because the
walls of a wormhole attract each other
which is why the wormhole would probably
close shortly after it opened unless you
had some exotic matter don't get too
excited exotic matter is negative energy
and it's what you'd need in order to
repel the gravitational forces trying to
bring the walls of the wormhole together
unfortunately it's unlikely that such
matter even exists in our universe but
if you're already set on making a trip
across the universe there's just one
more thing you should know the laws of
physics say that you wouldn't be able to
put enough negative energy into a
wormhole to keep it from collapsing but
on the bright side that rule hasn't been
tested yet so giddyup space cowboy right
on prove their existence and we'll try
to develop the necessary technology in
your absence but even if we could create
wormholes and travel through them would
it be worth it is it worth tilting the
earth and rearranging the solar system
just to visit another galaxy or go back
in time read your history read your
science fiction see all the movies and
play all the games you want but let's be
glad our solar system is the way it is
would we even be here if it wasn't
[Music]
[Applause]